i believe
guillermo was doing a frankenstein and
he just sort of said
that you would be frankenstein's monster
and i kind of love that story because
it sounded like you were just like well
if he says it it must be true it was
sort of
an unofficial thing and obviously a
thousand things have changed since then
but i'm i've i've always been curious
what a doug jones frankenstein's monster
would look like is that something you
thought of is that sort of
well at the time um yeah you know if
you've heard this story before then you
know that i heard about this
on the red carpet of the hellboy 2
premiere i was being interviewed by
by a print journalist at the very end of
the line right just ready to go in and
watch the movie
and he said doug i just talked to
guillermo and he said he's going to make
his own frankenstein movie what do you
think about that
i'm like i think that's a great idea no
one better to tell the story than him
and i know that's a beloved property
that he
you know he grew up wanting you know
that inspired his career so it's perfect
he said well that's not all
i asked him who he won for his monster
he said you i'm like
that's when i you know i i think i wet
my pants and
and thought like this is the first i'm
hearing about it but guillermo i was
happy to talk to a journalist about it
so uh i i did confirm with guillermo the
next day
and and for sure yeah and he said yeah
no that's that's why that's like that's
all in the works
okay and this is 2008. so it's been it's
been talked about even longer uh
so so as far as i knew it was in pre
it was in the development at universal
studios
uh and then but then i think i think
again this is me guessing again these
decisions are all above
doug jones pay grade uh but i i believe
guillermo was working he this was in
development for a couple years
and then the idea to do what kind of
what marvel's doing where there's an
entire universal monsters universe where
you set up the stories so they can
interplay with each other and make guest
appearances in each other's movies and
that kind of thing
and i believe that that that new era was
going to start with the new mummy movie
that
tom cruise was a part of does that sound
right yeah yeah it was the dark universe
it was a big thing that
dark university right right and so uh so
but i had i'm just my guess would be and
again this is i
have no authority to say this but but um
my guess would be that gamble probably
wasn't
he probably wanted to make a stand-alone
movie that was just his piece of art
that would be an homage to the book
and to the original film but um that's
just my guess
but uh so so i have not heard hiding her
hair of that uh
that idea since but um i i would again
if offered i would
i would kill to play yeah well anything
guillermo does i i i'm happy he knows
i'll say yes to whatever and then i'll
find out about what
what's the story later that's fine he's
the one director i could i trust with
whatever he offers me
over the years as has it ever you know
you know just
maybe when you're alone you do pops into
your head what
how you would interpret frankenstein's
monster because it to me you know i feel
like your casting would be
it's it's it's not what people picture
physically it's not right
and that was my first thought too is i'm
not the big you know the big broad big
boned
lumbering frankenstein that you're that
you're have in mind
uh but it was it was told me that that
uh that
guillermo is a huge fan of bernie
wrightson and a friend a friend of
bernie wrightson
uh at the time um and bernie had done
artwork
uh he he had illustrated there's an
illustrated version of mary shelley's
frankenstein out there
and all of the images of of
frankenstein's monster in that
that's what he was going to pattern my
look after which is was more emaciated
a little skinnier little with more drawn
uh a little
a little more pathetic looking uh and
yet
um had had a an unnatural uh
uh physical prowess and an unnatural
athleticism to him
uh anybody but he was sewn together with
spare parts of other of
you know a couple of different bodies
and very bony face
and very drunk long stringy drawn hair
and
yeah so i uh never went through a makeup
test myself
for it but i did i did this
i did go to the creature shop that was
uh spectrum ocean was was
developing the look for him at the time
there's another beginning this is back
in 2000 maybe nine or ten
um that i was in the i was in the
creature shop for something else
and and uh mike i was already the owner
of the shop said i gotta show you
something and he unveiled this
head and shoulders bust of me with this
monster makeup
built on it and it was like i mean i
honestly my eyes welled up it was so
hauntingly beautiful and it did it did
uh pay reference to bernie wrightson's
artwork
and also uh and gave you a different
looking frankenstein
monster than what you're used to